chuckle great topic for me would be
staying committed to life change I start
strong and fade fast into old habits
please help I'm gonna I'm gonna have to
bring in a little Shakespeare on this
one
Shakespeare between the acting of a
dreadful thing and the first motion all
the interim is like a Fantasma or a
hideous dream and that's Brutus from
Julius Caesar and Brutus in the play is
plotting to kill Caesar someone he was
loyal to in Shakespeare the master of
understanding human nature he captures
what that feels like and here's what
these lines mean between the acting of a
dreadful thing so that's the moment that
moment when you're waiting to do
something that you don't want to do and
the first motion so that's when you
actually start doing that thing that you
don't want to do all the interim now
this is all that time all that time in
that moment while you are waiting to
take action is like a Fantasma or a
hideous dream so that moment that moment
when you're waiting to do something it's
like an apparition a hideous dream a
nightmare and so the battle
struggle it takes place in that moment
it's not knowing what to do that's not
the battle it's not actually doing it
that's not the battle it's the moment in
between it's the hesitation hesitation
is the enemy and in war understanding
where the enemy is allows you to defeat
him and this is where the enemy of
action the enemy of commitment the enemy
of change that's where the enemy lies it
lies in the waiting and all you have to
do to win is overcome that moment the
waiting the hesitation all you have to
do is go move take action get out of bed
get your feet on the ground
step into the gym put down the doughnut
and pick up the kettlebell do not
hesitate do not wait go forward go to
war and win every single
time